moon night is steering marvel down a
dark path we hope to never return from
let's take a look at how they handled
this show behind the scenes number one
we're happy to hear they put so much
consideration into this oscar isaac
really pushed for the mental health to
be taken seriously pointing out that
there's a difference between trying to
cover your bases so you don't get called
out and actually caring about the people
watching it who might be suffering as
well before the camera started rolling
the team were working hard to not
exploit anyone's trauma by using it as a
backstory or plot device the story and
filmmaking became entirely about the
character trying to heal from trauma
ultimately take the mental health aspect
incredibly seriously number two like
every marvel suit the moon knight
costume was not made with comfort in
mind but they did think to include a
cooling mechanism underneath literally
cooler is the mr knight outfit uh
there's less layers i think the mr
knight is kind of the baddest looking
costume i've ever seen but may would
have to disagree i'd say the moon knight
costume looks cooler but the mr knight
costume has a much cooler entrance
number three first thing we must say is
oscar isaac is rocking the silver hair
now just imagine him doing all the stunt
work in the suit the level of dedication
from isaac is unquestionable from
martial arts to knife fights he is in
tip-top shape number four this is the
plotline of so many movies except make
the a-lister a kid with dreams from a
small town oscar isaac is the reason
ethan hawk got his role he ran into
isaac at a coffee shop while he was with
his daughter maya this isn't super out
of the blue the two only live like three
blocks from each other and he starts
telling me about moon night and i'm like
cool that sounds great because would you
be the bad guy hawk got the offer by
dinner there wasn't a script he just
said yes because he likes oscar isaac i
smelled something great so yeah i did it
number five swear not by the moon the
inconstant moon david koresh was
character inspiration for ethan hawk the
moon knight is inconstant then the
villain needs to be constant so hawk
started seeing his character more like a
sun figure he felt he should have long
hair like a lion like a sun if isaac's
character is a fractured person then
hawk needs to be really whole and gentle
and kind or of course he needed to be
seen that way
number six may was inspired by herself
she had no interest in making her
character cool and sexy saying that's
not me i'm the spaz who falls down and
so i wanted to bring that to her because
i feel like that makes up a whole woman
every woman i know is this dichotomy of
traits at the end of the day she just
wanted to feel real number seven pro tip
if you can't solve the cube just remove
the stickers and re-stick them i can
really do rubik's cube by the way you're
kind of like a genius
talk about a fun skill to put on your
resume do you think they included the
cube when they found out he could do it
or do you think he had to audition for
the part by doing the cube or do you
think he lied on his resume and then
panic learned from youtube tutorials
number eight it all started in the
theater what gets oscar isaac to say yes
to a project is he wants to know if
there is space for him to be creative is
there space for me to actually bring
something
new and interesting to it for isaac
that's more important than the character
or the director or the script he had a
lot of fun collaborating with marvel
because it felt like they really got to
create moon knight together from the
ground up
isaac and hawke are both theatrically
trained which although theater and film
skill sets are pretty different
character development remains the same
they kind of have a theater approach to
the craft and they really dig into it
you know number nine for most movies you
ask for a bus and you get a bicycle
ethan hawk's been acting since he was 13
but the marvel sets are the best sets
he's ever been on hawk was feeling just
a bit intimidated by the sky's the limit
budget if you want a crane you get five
if you want a chopper we got three
anything you can dream up they make
happen number 10. the struggle was real
the mini-series is such a weird
transitional animal between movies and
series not tv not a movie it felt very
movie-like other than lack of filming
time honestly it was like a master class
every day the tone of filming was a bit
odd too moon night is a globetrotting
action adventure an intense character
study on the moon night pages um things
go bump in the night so it's a little
bit spookier than some of the other
marvel stories and there's also a need
for the humor that's evident in the
broader marvel cinematic universe it was
fun but it was also like you're aware of
the circumstance that you're in and
technically filming it was scary for me
at times number eleven do you think the
actors stayed in the grand budapest
hotel the egyptology overlay is
something marvel hasn't done before they
filmed in the museum of fine arts in
budapest hungary which fun fact black
widow's primary shooting location was
also budapest filming in jordan captured
the egyptian atmosphere it feels like
marvel is trying to keep their edge over
dc delving into the darkness truly for
the first time with white batman at the
helm they're doing what dc does best and
doing it better which suit do you like
more the moon night or mr night let us
know in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things